une colonne de fumée s'élève de la
banlieue de coupiance tout juste
reconquise par les troupes ukrainiennes
prennent désormais position sur les
hauteurs les habitants ne prêtent plus
attention au départ de fou
beaucoup partent leur ville est détruite
et loin d'être sécurisée
les positions des militaires
[Musique]
avec les petites groupes militaires là
se situe l'enjeu pour les Ukrainiens
continuer la contre-offensive tout en
sécurisant les arrières nous sommes dans
la base d'un bataillon des forces
spéciales ukrainiennes c'est ce
bataillon qui a cassé les premières
lignes de défense russe et ces hommes
continuent aujourd'hui la
contre-offensive le major clever son
surnom et l'un des commandants du
bataillon les Russes selon lui montrent
toujours la même faiblesse
chez nous les décisions de terrain sont
prises rapidement par les commandants
qui sont sur le terrain ils ont toute
l'attitude pour décider
l'armée russe est toujours fixée sur un
système vertical s'ils n'ont pas le feu
vert du plus haut gradé l'infanterie ne
bouge pas c'est ce qui nous permet les
aplatir
cinquantaine de kilomètres au sud au
lexandre Emira hello surveille les
berges de l'hoskill la rivière coule
jusqu'à la région du Dombasle
accroupiance les Ukrainiens sont
parvenus à la traversée mais ici c'est
encore la ligne de front
une balle siffle à proximité ils nous
ont tiré dessus ici hier
c'est la position 0 en face c'est les
connards de russe notre rôle c'est de
surveiller que personne ne traverse ou
ne repère nos positions pour que notre
artillerie et notre armement ne soient
pas détruit on ne doit pas laisser
passer leur groupe de reconnaissance on
veille aussi à ce que les Russes qui
n'ont pas eu le temps de s'enfuir sur
l'autre côté de la rive ne s'approche
pas ne prospective
ah ça c'est les tirs de leur tank
nombre de soldats russes sont encore
bloqués côté ukrainien
cette semaine l'unité de l'exandre en a
capturé 10 certains dissimulés dans les
roseaux des berges de la rivière